I'm back baby I'm back [ __ ] this [ __ ]
life it's too hot in here okay
I'm ready I mean I'm ready for the first
time welcome I'm gonna play a little bit
hardest level in in the world oh it's so
difficult shut up shut your mouth where
is it piece of [ __ ] lever where is it
where is it
give me that stormy ascent apparently
they deleted this level off the game
because it was too hard
boohoo the game is too hard delete this
level it's too hard for me
blah nonsense no level is too hard I've
never died a single time and this is my
first time ever playing this level so
let's see how it goes okay
shall we I got new energy from nothing
okay this is the firt zero deaths by the
way and gives you new to my channel I am
a [ __ ] I am a pro gamer not a [ __ ]
look at my intuition [ __ ] you many vato
pizza there it is easy as squeezing a
teat see that totally rhyme thank you
I could beat this level blindfolded
playing with my butt cheeks that's how
easy this is actually I'm doing it right
now
come on zero deaths come on come on
bebut first checkpoint don't need it but
I'll take it just to to make you guys
happy zero deaths
oh you thought I was gonna die [ __ ]
zero mother flippin das Buch [ __ ] you
molesting Maine easy look at this jump
easy yeah second checkpoint as Abidjan
yeah easy I killed my cell phone perfect
zero deaths everyone that was a glitch
in the matrix something happened I don't
know what get up on it you [ __ ] [ __ ]
can you not
here we go again
here he goes again zero deaths zero
[ __ ] death another checkpoint thank
you
don't need them because I never die ever
[ __ ] I [ __ ] up now this part is
impossible
what look at that [ __ ] boy oh nice my
[ __ ]
how did I do it now Jesus skills [ __ ]
Jesus oh my god
when do I jump then you schmuck
I want to beat this [ __ ] level so
hard when do I [ __ ] jump you [ __ ]
piece of piss piss take this [ __ ]
level hey everyone welcome Monday majest
welcome I'm a pro gamer gamer five
everyone
I'm gonna play this game thank you never
died before
bye melon deaths in six months [ __ ] you
I'm not going to make that jump look at
that [ __ ] boy I fly through this level
like a fly fly through the Sun and burns
itself to death thank you Jesus first
checkpoint dab on them
what the [ __ ] cake stop
thank you Jesus
second checkpoint dab on dog oh my lord
oh my fist me daddy yes come on come on
come on
yes [ __ ] a dirt first checkpoint down
Fulham hater it's too bad this part is
virtually [ __ ] impossible without
getting hurt
see it's [ __ ] impossible I don't even
know why I [ __ ] tried Oh in the end
it doesn't even matter [ __ ] yeah
that's it easiest jumps come on come on
come on man I need these I need these
lives otherwise I'm dead this jump is
tricky
[ __ ] okay well great I'm dead I'm dead
now I'm dead now are you happy are you
happy are you happy are you [ __ ]
happy
yes
[ __ ] off come on cool I have so many
[ __ ] lines not that I [ __ ] need it
zero [ __ ] done
come on
what that
oh Jesus
laughing the thought what happened now I
definitely don't have one
oh my god
yes this [ __ ] jump sucks so much dick
yeah that will do the trick
[ __ ] oh that y'all I get it now
I [ __ ] get it now I get it now I
[ __ ] get it oh I want to do it so bad
[ __ ] you come on you pissed boy oh my
god you're so stupid
oh yes Sara [ __ ] Beth oh oh look you
game just like Dark Souls just like Dark
Souls [ __ ] you I respect woman and only
[ __ ] [ __ ] hell yeah like for [ __ ]
[ __ ] you god [ __ ] damn it